test assessing reading and math skills
of clark county school district students
reveals
a possible learning loss during distance
education no real surprise there
kristin drummond however joins us live
in the newsroom with these results and
areas of concern kristen
kirsten students from kindergarten
through 10th grade took the map
growth assessment last month which
stands for measure of academic progress
it identifies what children know and
what they're expected to learn by the
end of the school year but
some question the results during
distance education
it's not helpful at all to look at these
test scores
a father's frustration with the map
assessment
for them to call this a standardized
test when there's no standardization
whatsoever
josh curtis has four children in ccsd
schools
he says most did not perform well my
kindergartner he his map testing he
identified zero out of 26 letters
the fifth grader went horrible she went
she declined
slightly the results reveal only 84
percent of ccsd
students participated in the test this
data set
shows the projected proficiency between
third and eighth grade
students in grades three four and six
are expected to achieve
grade level reading proficiency at or
above the national average by the spring
as highlighted in green i know a lot of
people have been reading more
since but you know since a lot of
activities are removed
during the pandemic rebecca garcia is
the nevada parent teacher association
president
while she notices slight improvement the
math findings remain
troubling the expected math proficiency
for students in grades four
five six seven and eight is below the
national projection
but she questions the accuracy of the
findings
is this really where everybody's at or
is this a reflection of kind of
taking it in such a unique environment
some parents
not stressing about the results so at
this point
i i'm not concerned at all
while curtis wants the district to toss
them out i don't even know why they took
it seriously they even did it
if if you can't really get reliable
results
now some in the district tell me the
results for kindergarten through second
grade were skewed at schools because
of likely additional help in the homes
reporting live in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now